もう動画のタイトルとサムネイル見ればわかると思うんですけども
その通りなんです何かもうできるだけまっせ様と思ってて僕の中で結果を下げてきたん
ですけども
機能ですねお風呂入って上がって合うてこうやって髪の毛刺さってやってておおっと
いい感じで乾いてきたなぁと思ってかんなぎこうやって
上通りを確かめたいところ
んですかこうやってやったら
20本くらい髪だけついてました
花火社長です
ダメかなアプレ増えちゃうのかな
わからないんですよまあ巻第一マジでこれが果たして抜きゲなのか綺麗なのかもわかん
ないんですけどもうとりあえず今方風呂入ったりして上がったりするとものすごい量の
気が抜けたり落ちたりするんですよ
でも見てる人は分からないと思うんですけどもうめちゃくちゃ多いんでねすごい方です
けど多分減ってるんでしょうねほんとにもう目に見ては枯れない髪の毛抜けて正
年かなーっていう年でも髪の毛が抜け始めてるっていう説と今年の夏もブリッジ78回
やったんでもうか容疑が純正に歌魅せ技で敵れげっていう可能性あとはもう不殺生です
ね
なんか食生活滅茶苦茶すぎてそれで髪の毛が抜けてるのかっていう可能性もあるんで
どっちにしろこのペースで何か髪の毛が抜けてっていくとおそらく1年後には僕坊主に
なっています
エイ
でもですね皆さんどれくらい髪の毛抜けてる方コック実は知らない人だって友達がお
風呂に上がった時に亀田家な本当に抜ける買ったばかります
わからないと思うんですよね普段た女友だちとの会話でも紙投げオフローダーにどれ
ぐらい付けるエアた事故6本がなえっ俺柔軟さんみたいな回だって絶対受けないと思う
んですよ
なぜこれを機に皆さんに聞きたい服ローラーに髪の毛
な
小暮抜けますかネットによると1日にカメラ期間だけど放送は100本近くになる
らしいんですけども僕を黒入って上がって髪の毛こうするだけで1日の5分の1を
終わりますからやばいよはハゲちゃうちょっと空けられないなら僕が良いんですけど
もう今多いんでどっち白このまっすぐ個セットマジでやばいような気がするんでまあ
とりあえず今日はですねお風呂上がりに大丈夫考え南本田に抜けるかというの
皆さんに診てもらおうと思いますなんでこんな売りそうなんだろうけどまずはお風呂に
入っていきます
思いません
[拍手]
一応払い終わりました化学
急なことでちょっとだけが上がってすぐあれだけ落としているゾーンに行こう止めます
ねは
さあはい好きで早速髪の毛を抜いていこうと思いますが脱ぐと言ってもあの自然に
落ちる奴だけですけどね乾かしたりするときに隙間
怖いよみんなにあげてやるちゃうけどまあいいや
ウール
あつってたら値超えた今
うんんあーやばいやばい超できてきてるそれは軽いだけ黒い黒いからたばもうはい始め
てる奴だこれ
やっぱなんでこんな風に音はの
うわぁ
レイヤーにおつるやんげー
わー
違う俺は
だが今のでさんは死んだよ
吉田義じゃねえはもう大丈夫そうですモンドいけないですけど頭皮にくっついてるん
じゃなくても抜けをつかみ向けなんすかこれぐらいですどうぞ
いや結構多いぞこれこんな感じでめっちゃ抜けてますねー
はい
やわけない結構で何か黒いせようってこともねっここと言ってるのもなぁ本カーって方
じゃん普通とわかりづらくて申し訳ないんですけども結構抜けてます
改めて目で見るとマジでやばいんだったと思う
結果52本でした
終わったぁーパワー編みて曲がった後に52本抜けてるんですよ手で3分とかで体に
上がってる時にもっと落ちてるかもしれないですよゆーで100本超えてるぜと抜け
てる量が
ハゲ散らかるか結構やえええええええ
どうすればいいのなんで髪が傷んでる可能性もあるんでそれわかんないですけど
どっちもなんかわかんねえ感覚的に最近資源抜きすぎてるなっていう気でします日目
だけがあった佐手小だわざとハゲ散らかってまぁ
まずくなるともう僕風呂から上がって壁で洗い流した状態でも50日本で受けてるんで
た風呂入った
あってかがせられたんです23秒が飛んでるのかなと思います何でなんだろやっぱ歳な
のかなぁややだ
でもたくさん染めてるからその痛みが迫ると思うってかそう思いたいがそうだと思うよ
ねー
やばいよやばいも染竹内とにティアナちょっと皆さんがどれくらい髪飛び抜けてるのか
気になりますよかったら風呂上りに何分抜けてるか教えてくださいちょっとそれ参考に
すれば後洗い流すトリートメント塗ってくるバイバイッ
me
あっはぁ